so you guys heard a little bit from
Brian about what recap is and so I'm
going to go into a little more detail
about that I'm going to tell you more
about pacer and I'm going to talk about
things we sort of thinking about for two
point oh and I won't have time for
questions but I want to plant a seed in
your minds with a question that I do
have for you guys and I'm sure at some
point we'll have time to talk about it
so what is recap Brian talked about this
earlier but before you can really get
into what recap is you have to
understand what pacer is so pacer is the
public access to court electronic
records system it is a database that's
maintained in about 200 individual
locations that you take the software and
the court installs it in its own
location and then they tweak it in their
own little way and so you get these
interesting sorts of similar websites
but different they said recently they
have a billion documents so we think
this is the biggest possibly in the
world probably in the United States the
biggest paywalled collection of public
domain documents that we know of its
it's truly massive and the cost for
these ten cents per page cap it three
dollars per document and also search
results cost a dime per page funny thing
about search results you don't know how
big they are until you've paid so you
put in a query and you get back a
thousand results well that's going to be
10 bucks there's no cap on that you get
back two thousand results that's going
to be 20 bucks and you've already paid
by the time you see the results it's
it's done so be careful what you search
for especially if you're playing with it
because the first thing you do when you
play with the system is do a search you
will then be paying so be careful if you
leave this lightning talk and decide to
play with it as I did Lehman Brothers if
you want to download everything from
that I think it's the biggest one we've
ever seen but just to download
everything in that case
27 thousand dollars assuming six pages
per item and it was built in 1997 and
it's not really been updated it's really
it looks like this you can see their big
warning search results from the screen
are not subject to the 30 page limit on
pacer charges be specific as possible
with your search criteria where
librarians here we know that searching
is a matter of going abroad and the
narrowing so is this really search even
I don't know but I think my conclusion
here is it's really bad like it's it's
very bad so that's our backdrop and on
to that what we've done and actually was
started at the Center for information
technology policy at Princeton and were
collaborating on it now is they wrote a
couple of browser extensions originally
was just for Firefox there's one for
chrome now too what you do is you
install these you use pacer as you
normally would whenever you buy a
document we get a copy we send it to the
internet archive and if anybody has ever
looked at the document that you want and
you're about to purchase will inject a
little icon next to it this is get it
for free and so we recapped about three
and a half million items so far and
they've been downloaded many many many
times saving people a lot of money so
that's sort of the backdrop for that
there are some problems Firefox has
changed a lot since it was first created
so the code is now getting to be a
little bit old and need some love
chromes been a little bit better it only
works with pacer so the question I want
you guys think about is are there other
repositories of public domain documents
that we should be thinking about already
we've identified alameda county courts
where we're in Alameda County California
they're even crazier it's a dollar per
page
you can imagine this gets expensive and
this isn't what justice should look like
in our opinion it it means that people
with more money have more access to
documents more access to documents mean
that you can do you have better tools
that are tools mean you have a bet if
you have an edge and when you come into
the court and that's not the way we want
to do it so I've only got five minutes
that's pretty much it and I'll hand it
off to members next next up is dragon
dragon espen sheet from r is rhizome you
can set up hi I think the set-up time
opening tabs doesn't count yeah these
long domain names
oh it's here already so okay um these
are just three links and I want to point
out at at rhizome which is a digital
arts nonprofit that has been founded
1996 on the web and exists mainly on the
web and we have been dealing with the
rap since yeah since the web with
artists and art work and so the main
difference I think to the other
institutions that we're presenting here
is that we don't see the web as a medium
that points to something but we see the
web more as a condition in itself and it
doesn't have content for us but it's
more an activity that people do and it's
also for shown or the continuous
publishing space where there is the URL
and the time that you access so there's
just no we don't have this idea of
documents and I want to show it on a
very simple example in what direction we
are going here so there is an artwork by
Yann Hobart late game which is called
scrollbars untitled school bus which
looked like that during the time the
screen shot was made which is here this
beautiful quadratic Gail scrollbars but
I can look at it now as well and thanks
to it to using microsoft windows here
which is the operating system that most
people have never seen in their lives
because they don't work in
administration or in no actually that's
true i mean scroll bars are already
something very exotic but there is no
content here on these pages there's
absolutely nothing here there's only
scroll bars so on so we this was the
first version how it was archived in
2000 which is just the artist handed
over files to us and we put them on the
server of course this is very much from
the process of how artwork so the artist
comes and hands over something this
doesn't work anymore very much
especially since artists move to work on
social media most of the time now and
they don't have anything they can and
over anymore we are using also we are
using here on our weapon x server we are
using again the PI way back framework
that Ilya Kramer has developed and we
are working very closely with him to
develop it further also the web recorder
project so here now at least we have the
original URL part of the thing of the
archive that that is very that is the
original URL is also part of the of the
web but sins and since we are dealing
here with the with a piece that was made
in the year 2000 and the end the scroll
was practically don't exist anymore we
are working here with together with the
university of freiburg that we just want
a major research grant together with
them we integrate it here this is the
first step to integrate web archives
with emulations so this is not fully
transparent yet so at the moment the
emulator is aware that it needs to
connect to another system but you see
here this is very close to the year 2000
actually here with this and of course
because again the web is not documents
anymore I mean it may be used to be for
a few months after Tim Bernoulli's put
it out there but I love how the scroll
bars are destroying themselves here this
is just beautiful and but the the thing
is that the web is not a document
delivery system kind of it's a software
it's a software delivery system and
maybe it's even a distributed one
software thing so this is how we are we
are approaching it and this is also
about the excess how access is given is
is very crucial here so at some point
why we have our web archives and many of
them are accessible in a meaningful way
meaningful way for a few years at some
point browsers will change our user
interface parody news will change
much that we will need to shift them
into emulation but we are we are using a
very soft going from actual browser to
emulate a browser so it can it can
travel and now let me quickly point you
to I will leave this wobbling in this
window and when it comes what we are
very interested in as an artistic
organization we are very interested in
high fidelity web captures which means
like that for example we can this is a
web site of a brilliant gallery that
uses loads of Vimeo embeds and
background videos and everything we did
archive that just by looking at it with
web recorder which is the tool that a
jar crema developed and we we did a lot
of development together so let me
quickly show you what is possible there
just as a quick I'm of course I'm of
every quarter user and everybody who's
serious about web archiving should have
a beta account there let me show you
here this tweet by Edward boss member of
X member of british parliament which is
one of the famous weird politician
tweets in the history of social media he
just tweeted at boss and it got really
popular but but not more than a year
later Saudis was tweeted in two thousand
eleven and two thousand twelve this
gentleman picked it up and made it
famous and but the thing is here you see
I'm locked in here into this archived
version I'm locked in because otherwise
if I wouldn't be logged in I wouldn't be
able to read the thousands and thousands
of answers that are attached to this
tweet and here at that point when I
archive did six notifications were
waiting for me and yeah tomorrow in this
session beyond crawling I will
demonstrate in detail how that goes how
that works but yeah so this is a you see
also yeah it's it's loading here
but not not a single bit is actually
coming from the Twitter service here and
of course the where is it here rhizomes
Facebook page I also logged in here as I
don't have a facebook account so this is
a fake account here but we are also able
to log into Facebook and then start
archiving it by it but just from looking
at it so everything that I did was to
paste the facebook URL in here that I
want and then I start scrolling down and
everything that I see automatically goes
through the walk alright and details on
that tomorrow thank you I will very cool
all right Jefferson you wanted your
lightning talk for five minutes you did
we could you said you would improvise as
I recall thanks i'm not prepared but i
was going to talk about a new project
that we've been working on so i'm from
internet archive and i was going to talk
about research services so i think some
people in the room are going to
so next week asree saw a conference in
Denmark that'll be a lot of researchers
and we have been working on providing
research services in internet archive in
a couple of ways and I'll talk about
first the background and then these and
walk through it so our goal we generally
in the past have worked mostly on large
data set research services with web
scientist with computer science to
scientist and other sort of big research
initiatives that have their own
infrastructure as far as compute
clusters to deal with the size of data
that we're giving them which is usually
somewhere between 50 and 200 terabytes
or something like that so you know I
think when we talking about collection
building a lot here and collaborations
it's not just a cross curatorial efforts
but it's also across access methods and
I think web archiving has been very URL
Centrex in its access methods and so
we're trying to figure out ways and I
think all the community is trying to
figure out ways to enable access methods
that are not entirely URL centric and
that can support data mining and digital
humanities and other and similar efforts
using large large collections even small
arc of it collections are you know
multiple terabytes and obviously are our
own collection is many petabytes and
that is challenging in many ways for the
types of research that data driven
scholarship is interested in doing so
what are access models that have been
successful are not been successful in
this area we've tried giving people data
and letting them running it on their own
cluster that is sometimes successful but
the research outputs are not necessarily
scalable to the larger community another
method that we've tried is giving people
access to shared clusters sort of
something like Amazon AWS are similar
Hadoop in the cloud giving people free
accounts and putting data in there for
them to play with there so that compute
costs are actually subsidized by us or
by a third
but they can still work at scale without
having their own infrastructure so that
one is successful but needs a lot of
hand-holding it requires pretty good
tech chops and programming or comp sci
postdocs working for you so successful
and that it doesn't require the actual
hardware but not successful in that it
requires a lot of hand-holding generally
on our part or by data engineers that
are somehow affiliated with the project
so a new one that we've tried is we do
all the processing and give people
derivative data sets that would then
power their research and allow them to
do the type of text mining network
analysis and other sort of easy to do
big scale analysis scholarship inquiry
kind of questions but using data sets
that are derived from the entirety of a
collection and so then do not present
challenges of processing scale are you
know needing specific programming
expertise so this is it we've launched
it we started with archive it because
the collections themselves are smaller
so this is something that would
hopefully eventually be rolled out in
some shape or form to internet archive
more broadly with the web collection
which is you know 10 to 15 petabytes or
something like that but archival
collections are generally a they're
curated they have lots of metadata
curator supplied metadata they crawl at
great periodicity so crawl frequency is
much easier to predict then with our
global crawls which tend to happen for a
long period of time they sort of happen
regularly but not super regularly we get
donations of web data from other sources
that are not are crawling so archive it
provides a good platform for giving
specific starting with specific
collections that are pretty well
contained and then doing derivation out
of there so the three that we've started
with and some of these we've been using
internally for crawl prioritization
collection QA and we just use it on the
backend for many different things and
there wats LGA's and wanes and what
those mean
and I don't have time and didn't prepare
like the great visualizations that we've
done internally but we'll put them
online and we're also be putting up
tutorials as well as sample data sets
from some public collections that we
create internally so it's not anybody's
data that we have to give away so we'll
be putting up both works as well as
derivative data sets as well as
tutorials and walks through that go all
the way from the raw data to
visualization and analysis and and
network graphs and stuff like that so
the three that we've started with as the
pilot project or wats LGA and waiting so
wat is basically a sort of key metadata
elements from the work so enough to do
text mining like page title and anchor
text and meta text and stuff like that
also has provenance data so all the
capture data for the resource is
included and then all inbound and
outbound links as well so there's
linking behavior text and capture
information graph information is
basically collection level and that is
every resource that links to every
resource across an entire archive a
collection so it's just a big composite
file linking behavior that you can do
network analysis and things like that
and these all of course have time stamps
and things like that so you can do them
longitudinally and then they Mitch the
extractions when I'm excited about so
it's Stanford name to teach any our
software run across an entirety of a web
collection and it just extracts all the
names people places organizations ties
them to you our eyes and gives them a
timestamp so what we've been doing after
sort of starting with these and there's
plenty of other data sets in the works
is doing things like putting them in
their own search engines elasticsearch
is when we've been using the holy lk
stack so you'd be able to do actual you
know text searching within the
collections but then also sort of
faceting on the fly for document
discovery trend analysis it comes with
its own sort of visualization platform
so you can build you know charts and
graphs and things like that all within
the web browser so that's research
services trying to figure out how to
provide more access to web archives writ
large thanks
Thanks Jefferson and Jefferson is as he
may be may or may not be aware is
facilitating a session tomorrow on
analysis of data services so it analysis
of web archive data so if you have any
follow-up conversation you like to have
with him about anything you just
mentioned I encourage you to go to that
tomorrow so we have now we have Dan shut
not for one more lightning talk and then
after that we'll have Jack and then
we'll be moving on to our next session
thank you I'm going to be is so I type
here and look there sorry I'm going to
be as quick as i can because i'm really
excited to hear Jimmy and Ian and I
don't want to cut into their time to
present ok so I'm Dan shutting off from
george washington university libraries
and washington DC laura ruble who had
intended to come since her regrets she
couldn't make it so i get to stand here
and let you wonder about this for a
moment i want to tell you about a
project we've been working on for almost
four years called social feed manager if
you search for social feed manager you
should find it up at the top of the
results on any particular search engine
you tried this is a tool we developed in
response to specific researcher needs to
work with a social media data we found
social scientists on campus doing really
interesting studies but they were
managing data by hand literally
assigning students copying and pasting
tweets into excel so we automated that
and found that there other people on
campus doing that and have had some
success with the projects I want to tell
you some of the successes we've had what
we're working on right now and some
things we'd like to do next after we get
through that next phase i'm hoping some
of you might be interested in some of
those things too so for the last three
years like I said we've been collecting
data for a lot of different faculty
members and graduate students PhD
students seniors juniors doing capstone
projects master students and freshman we
just had a fresh a senior win and
undergraduate research prize
working out with Twitter data we've had
master students in political science
studying how Isis is using Twitter and
writing reports to the State Department
regularly we've had multiple faculty
members just published papers chapters
and books that sort of thing we
collected for example all of the tweets
from the major party candidates in every
midterm congressional race last year and
the full election and they study those
to look at the use of agenda references
and language and how those campaigns
expressed their opinions so it's it's
run largely social sciences sort of
spectrum but we found it's this great
outreach technique and a great way to
deliver the service we've always
delivered in libraries which is helping
people get going with the research by
delivering information to them three
years ago our good friend Mark Phillips
said hey Dan you guys should write an
IMLS grant because I want to use your
software and you know you'll need to
package it up Morris also i am alessa
probably fund you to package it up so we
wrote a grant and we got funded Thank
You IMLS thank you Mark and there's at
least I think three people in the room
that are running sfm now it's free
software under an MIT style license you
can have it you can use it please give
it a shot tell us what you think the
IMLS money helped us improve it and
document it we are currently working
under a grant from the NH PRC that is
focused in three areas and we're very
busy with all of those right now number
one is to expand the scope of the
software to be a little more
thoughtfully put together and to handle
multiple platforms we're going to have
twitter tumblr and flickr support as
well as a new grant we've just been
funded where we've partnered with johns
hopkins to collect chinese blogging
materials on chinese anti-corruption
campaign using archive it for web logs
and sfm for Weibo Weibo as I mentioned
is sort of like Chinese Twitter if
you've never used Chinese microblogging
it doesn't look like this what this is
is a visualization of a year and a
half's worth of data I collected for a
social science a political scientist a
PhD student who is studying
well it's pretty it's pretty subtle I
can't do his work justice but this is a
visualization of a summary of something
like 300 million Weibo records I
collected for him so it's nice to have
some Weibo experience so we're improving
the platform to be multi multi target
we're also making it much more
self-service previously you kind of had
to have one of us librarians pull some
levers for you we want researchers to be
able to define their own sets save it
push a button have the system go capture
stuff for them almost on their own and
finally probably the more important
thing we're working on right now the
most important thing relatives is our
comments keynote speakers comments this
morning we have a lawyer working with us
analyzing from a policy perspective
working with our archivist who is also
looking at collection development policy
description appraisal processing
strategies and we're going to go to our
general counsel's office to make sure
we're on good footing legally with what
we're doing we think we are and I don't
have time to talk about that and it's
201 so let me just finish by saying we
want to move into three new areas one is
figuring out how to present this stuff
when you have a billion things what sort
of interface to you provide a second
thing is to do analytics and study
what's in the data maybe provide some of
that to our social scientists
researchers to sort of further move them
along in their work so they can focus
even more in on their methods so they
can ask questions very thoughtfully and
finally to UM to understand how to
document the now to use a phrase from my
colleague burgess jewels who's at UC
Riverside how to understand something
like a political movement that's live
that's on the streams that's happening
that's developing what do you collect
how do you figure out dynamically what
to go out and grab what keywords are
arising what people are becoming leaders
and whose material should you collect I
think that's what we're going to try and
move into in the next year so if that
sounds interesting to you please come
find me but that's enough time thank you
so I promised I would only take one
minute for this so let's see if that's
possible I'm working on a project that i
would love input on it's an org here at
tools for time travel org which is about
building really that's not a thing
alright i'm already failing it one
minute I'm going to go backwards in time
1 minute and start now I'm working on a
project to build strong dark archives
which our archives that are
jurisdictionally distributed and
encrypted so that the archivists
themselves cannot read the material
until the release conditions are met
these are designed to store culturally
valuable materials that were otherwise
be deleted or never shared in the first
place if they can't be protected this
way so stories from the troubles in
Northern Ireland which the Belfast
project ran into problems with Hillary
Clinton's emails stories from cultural
conflict around the world the stuff that
we're losing now maybe we could keep if
we could offer strong enough protection
for I'm having a conversation a small
workshop on jun 18th at Harvard with a
bunch of people who have really
interesting thoughts about that if you
look at this and this likes your eyes up
I would love to talk with you about it
and I'd love to have you at our workshop
so come find me Thanks